on va parler de littérature dans le 7 8
les prix du livre de 50 ans en Yvelines
vont être remis ce samedi cette organisé
par le réseau des médiathèques de 50 ans
en Yvelines en partenariat avec marmite
FM et les librairies du pavé du canal à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et du pavé dans
la mare à Élancourt une journée festive
se tient pour l'occasion à 50 ans
Yvelines avec clou de l'événement la
remise des prix qui sera effectué par le
président du jury Daniel Picouly qui est
normalement connecté avec nous en
visioconférence bonsoir
normalement normalement
en tout cas vous êtes avec nous c'est
l'essentiel alors pour vous présenter
écrivain animateur de télévision vous
êtes aussi scénariste de bande dessinée
et vous allez proposer à l'occasion de
cet événement à cette remise de prix
votre one-man show pompette s'est adapté
de votre roman Les larmes du vin on va
en parler dans un instant mais j'ai une
première question pourquoi avoir accepté
d'être le président de ce prix du livre
de ces prix du livre de 50 ans en
Yvelines
d'abord parce qu'on me l'a demandé c'est
une bonne chose déjà et puis parce que
je travaille avec certains organisateurs
de salon que je connais bien en
l'occurrence Bertrand Morisset et Sarah
donc vous savez c'est un milieu on
travaille à l'amitié à la confiance on
sait que quand on va dans salon que
eux-mêmes ça se passera bien voilà donc
c'est c'est aussi ça aussi la vie
littéraire c'est des relations des
copains du coup avoir et des livres
c'est pas mal avec modération quand même
les coups à boire mais oui en tout cas
le programme
est établi aura une journée festive au
théâtre de 50 en Yvelines aussi à la
médiathèque du canal plusieurs choses
qui sont au programme on peut retrouver
d'ailleurs tout le programme détaillé
sur le site des médiathèques de 50 ans
en Yvelines le clou du spectacle c'est
la remise des prix à 17h15 et c'est une
journée mais bien deux prix qui vont
être remis Daniel Picouly avec le prix
du livre les visionnaires ça c'est le
premier
c'est le premier prix du livre de 50 ans
de vie il y a un autre prix qui
s'appelle le prix lire et choisir si
vous pouvez juste présenter ces deux
prix et quelle est la quels sont les
différences du coup entre entre ces deux
prix
le visionnaire vous voyez un petit peu
de quoi de quoi il s'agit des livres qui
se projettent dans pas seulement le
présent mais dans l'avenir et qui
essaie de nous éclairer un peu ce qu'il
en sera de notre avenir qui vous en
conviendrez c'est quelque chose de pas
très très simple aujourd'hui d'éclairer
l'avenir mais les
littérateurs les auteurs les autrices le
font et donc tout tout ouvrage qui nous
permet d'éclairer cette avenir qui
parfois en ce moment nous paraît un peu
ambuler l'expression gentille
les bienvenus et donc sera distingué
quelqu'un qui aura écrit quelqu'un qui
aura écrit un livre de cette nature là
faire du bien nous faire parallèle
c'est quand même aujourd'hui une
cinquième entreprise donc ça c'est pour
le prix des visionnaires on a vu les
auteurs et les ouvrages sélectionnés si
vous pouvez nous présenter justement ces
auteurs en quelques mots qui sont-ils et
pour quel roman justement ont-ils été
sélectionné
alors là moi j'ai pas j'ai pas tous les
éléments pour pour faire la présentation
et je voudrais pas dire de bêtises comme
vous avez vu on s'est installé dans
cette vision de façon un petit peu
impromptue sur moi je suis pas avec bon
je suis même pas dans mon bureau donc
vous voyez je veux pas me permettre
pour les préciser alors en lice GPS de
Lucie Rico il y a l'inventeur de Miguel
Bonnefoy et le dernier des sien de
Sybille grbbert donc ça c'est pour le
prix des visionnaires et donc je le
disais il y a un deuxième prix Daniel
picoulis c'est lire et choisir et alors
là la sélection a été opérée me semble
par les collégiens de 50 en Yvelines
c'est eux directement qui ont lu ces
ouvrages qui ont fait cette sélection
oui alors pour revenir au premier prix
faut quand même que que j'admette que le
livre de Miguel Bonnefoy m'a
particulièrement touché c'est un auteur
que j'aime beaucoup ce qui ne préjugent
rien bien évidemment de la vie mais il y
a dans cette sélection-là en tout cas un
livre qui qui me va droit au cœur pour
les
7 jours formidable quand un jury n'est
pas un jury de spécialiste je participe
à beaucoup de jurys qui sont comme ça
des fois à parité entre les écrivains ce
qui est formidable c'est que les
écrivains prennent une leçon parce que
les gens lisent et lisent très très bien
et prennent très à coeur leur rôle et je
peux vous assurer que dans ces jours là
on en revient des fois on vient avec
quelques certitudes et on croit même
pouvoir
non pas influencer mais faire avancer
son son avis on écoute et on s'aperçoit
que ces livres ont été très très
sérieusement et ça nous arrive et très
souvent non pas de changer d'avis
de reconnaître la vie des autres
et donc on va peut-être pouvoir voir
cette sélection s'affiche également pour
ce prix à lire et choisir et tout comme
le prix des visionnaires il y a trois
livres également qui sont en compétition
vous retrouver aussi toutes les
informations sur le site Internet des
médiathèques de 50 ans en ligne beaucoup
d'animations aussi à au programme de
cette journée festive Daniel picouli on
va en terminer par là il y aura
notamment aussi pour clôturer la journée
votre one man show pompette qui est tiré
de votre roman Les larmes du vin en
quelques mots de quoi ça parle et
pourquoi l'avoir adaptée en spectacle
alors d'abord parce que j'avais déjà
adapté un texte en spectacle ça
s'appelle la faute d'orthographe et ma
langue maternelle j'avais donné à
Avignon et puis dans un théâtre parisien
que ça me manquait et la pompette c'est
une espèce d'évidence pompette vous
voyez le petit bonhomme sur sur cette
affiche c'est moi et je suis dans le
ventre de ma maman et ma maman parce que
j'ai pas envie de sortir moi je suis
bien dans le monde de ma mère
m'envoie un petit coup d'abricotine
petit alcool Suisse
[Musique]
discussion vous avez appris beaucoup de
choses
qu'on les avait oublié donc j'ai voulu
essayer de refaire un petit tour du côté
de ma mémoire intra-utérine pour me
souvenir ce que j'entendais quand ma
maman était là et que j'étais dans son
compte et que ça discutait un peu désir
de faire du monde et beaucoup de moi
donc voilà c'est un peu cette idée là et
donc je vais raconter ma naissance et
mon baptême qui est pas mal bousculé
bien évidemment c'est un texte qui se
fait drôle parce que c'est quand même
drôle et amusant étonnant d'être dans le
monde de sa maman avec un petit coup
dans l'aile et donc ça ça refermera
cette journée festive sur ces prix du
livre de 50 ans lui merci Daniel Picouly
d'avoir été avec nous par visio
conférence la connexion est passée sur
la fin c'est un peu compliqué mais en
tout cas la connexion est passée à la
fin et donc je le rappelle grande
journée festive au programme ce samedi à
l'occasion de la remise des prix remise
des prix aux alentours de 17h15 juste
pour le préciser rendez-vous au théâtre
de 50 ans en Yvelines et la médiathèque
du canal toutes les informations sur le
site Internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran